[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où va le monde quand aider son prochain
passeport de l'héroïsme
[Musique]
quand vont oublier nos principes
nous vivons dans une société où les
chants sont aveugles
ce que vous ne voyez pas vous ne le
savez pas
[Musique]
loin des yeux loin de l'esprit
il s'est passé quelque chose cette nuit
quelque chose de terrible
nous mari ne retiendront pas
on est tout seul
ils ont volé beaucoup d'argent
et des gens nous le réclament
notre meilleur avantage c'est d'être qui
nous sommes
pourquoi parce que personne ne s'imagine
qu'on va avoir les couilles d'aller
jusqu'au bout
qui sommes nous dans ce monde nous force
à nous mettre à genoux
si ça tourne mal je veux que mes enfants
sachent que je me suis pas laissé faire
j'ai agi dans cette ville on récolte ce
qu'on sème
elle espère bleus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]